Malik I'm not going to ask you too much
about the game because it doesn't have a
lot of history but what was the strategy
going into today's round given that
you're one point ahead one point and a
half ahead of shabalov well I mean I
wanted to keep tension
um but I mean hey I kind of missed Queen
B6 movie in my preparation it's actually
very sneaky I didn't realize screaming
six we spoke briefly it's uh that's led
me to play D4 I thought he's playing D5
yes and um
I didn't see that kind of was coming so
I was trying to get position like this
with slightly Edge and then I realized I
had to play something like D3 because I
didn't want to play like nasty three
because Knight E5 yeah and I thought the
one is actually smart uh waiting move it
was a very good move yeah yeah but then
apparently he also
analyze this as well but then he'd been
debating As I understood like between
like rookie 8 and queen C6 so but I mean
okay if we play squishy6 that I mean
this General trade is supposed to be
just uh equal and and honestly the whole
time I I couldn't understand how to
behave how to play right right exactly
difficult yeah so
and I didn't want to take a risk here
because I don't think so I have anything
like particular
um
and a drug guarantees you the tie breaks
at least yeah but I don't I hope it's
not going to happen of course
at least you have something in your
apartment well actually tomorrow is
going to be much more easier for me to
uh to sort of psychologically play today
I couldn't sleep really I mean I slept
like maybe three hours top I mean I just
didn't know like okay what to do what to
do what to do I play like open Sicilian
do I play against night or like uh
kailano there do I play like a D4
against his like King sedan defense or
grundfell I like I didn't know like what
to do that situation when you sort of in
between yeah like are you hanging in
there I I just said he said you know
what it's I remember like when I was a
kid
um petrogen uh shared his story uh when
he played Curacao and when he was I
think he was uh halfway the hand right
yes I should remember better than me
history and
um he said this he was doing the same
stories he said so he couldn't control
him so it was a very difficult situation
and then he made just a draw and said
sir you know what whatever if it's going
to happen it's going to happen yeah
that's it so I kind of start to like
thinking think and think I said you know
what whatever let's let's do this let's
let's take a draw and then let's put
myself you know on the fate of the
history so we'll see we'll see what's
going to happen there's obviously a lot
riding on this couple of uh games tell
us a bit about your support system I'm
sure you need that whenever you have
this type of difficult nights not
sleeping what is your support system who
is your support system maybe it's about
um
my kids voice
yeah usually like before I go to bed I'm
calling home I'm talking to my kids and
that kind of uh come calm myself down
and um yeah and then I'm trying to also
have a couple of friends who is like
true friends to me and uh they always
try to be really nice to me and whenever
I feel like kind of you know difficult
moments I'm I'm kind of calling them or
texting them or something like that and
um yeah I mean I can't say I didn't
sleep like at all I slept obviously but
what I'm saying is you know whenever you
sleep and then whenever you see
something and then you like waking up
against sleep waking up you know
something like that but I mean it was
okay it's okay
I just woke up uh around like what 6
37ish
so that's fine
yeah I mean it's still a great position
to be in and as a competitor I'm sure
you dream about these type of moments in
every single game every single
tournament you're playing so yeah no
complaints you know it's like I also to
my students like imagine this if someone
would propose you to have this
situations before the event would you
take it I mean obviously I would take it
obviously yeah yeah I would take it but
I I realized shop is going to win
because I think it's airflow was really
terrible uh by goreevich but that's a
fine his his looking good right now yes
it's still not very far from over
already but anyway I thought okay
whatever well we'll see we'll see I like
to play Shabba so it's going to be a
very interesting matchup tomorrow yeah
guys I like this kind of intensity
guys any questions for Malik as he goes
into that final battle Yeah it's your
preparation and now
absolutely I love it I I love uh just
the story he was saying there because
when you hear him speak about you know
waking up in the morning and the first
thing that's on his mind is should I
play an open Sicilian should I do it
like this it's always very difficult
passionate about Chess that's what it's
about that passion it's it's in your
blood right yep exactly and good luck
good luck absolutely uh just turning our
attention to the game of Alice Lee for